hallo mein name ist luca und das neben
mir ist beim und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge nintendo wird
unglaublich oft die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich mit herrn lux mal
wieder bringen soll und alle meinten
blues hat durst
ich weiß selber noch von damals das ist
bei nintendogs der fall war wenn man
sich lange nicht um die kühe hunde
gekümmert hat also wochen und die letzte
folge ist wirklich schon wochen her dass
die hunde dann verhungern verdursten so
traurig sind dass sie weglaufen oder
dass sie einfach sterben können
deswegen schauen wir jetzt mal ob du gut
geht weil du lebt auf jeden fall dass
wir schon eine ganze nachricht ist mir
noch ein bisschen abgeneigt aber wenn
jetzt mal hier draufklicken sehen wir am
verhungern und verdursten ich hab
wirklich so einen schock bekommen als in
den kommentaren stand luca bringen
unbedingt die dann in jobs nicht das
blut an touristen nicht wieder so weit
die können ja wirklich verdursten aber
jetzt trifft der kleine knabe auf jeden
fall sicher erstmal bund und soffin will
ich das durchstehe braucht eigentlich
immer noch über luzon rote oder rote
schleife hier drum rum oder ich glaube
die gewichte in der nächsten folge mal
wieder freudig doch schon direkt wenn
der faktor ist immer noch total dreck
bevor ich in allerdings wasche gehe ich
nicht weil du es mal eine runde
spazieren und auch in die trainingshalle
damit wir gleich noch ein wettkampf
bestreiten können wenn wir nämlich den
wettkampf bestreiten könnte es sein dass
wir sogar heute noch genug geld bekommen
um beim nächsten mal einen neuen hof ein
geschenk heute seifenblasen die so freue
ich mich so vielleicht haben wir dann in
der nächsten folge schon wieso war es
klar es war einfach klar dass er wieder
pinkl vielleicht haben wir dann schon in
der nächsten folge genug geld um uns an
aber wir sind schon angekommen ja sehr
gut und weißer ring über die 23 sehr gut
und hier auch drüber lud und hier auch
nochmal genau so genau was du kannst der
kleine mann und richtig gut
bomba lupen schaffst das musst du musst
ihn aus er kommt kommt ja jetzt geschah
es nochmal balu damit möglich hin trägt
die super dessen fucking fehler wenn ich
auf diese arschlöcher du bist die wahl
sorgt gut und jetzt hier rüber weil
überkommt den trichter nie hin jetzt
jemand drüber genau und hier darüber
genau und jetzt machen wir nochmal hier
den doppelsprung
ich muss aber wirklich sagen dass man
who schon immer besser wird in diesem
ganzen parcours ding
allerdings heftig geworden man hier über
die rampe drüber genau hier stehen
bleiben balu und jetzt komm doch einfach
mit nach hause jetzt wo ich weiß aber
dass sich das training war ich super
eigentlich jahren auf viele krasse
sachen hingekriegt
wer du packst saal hin alter weil du
nein nein valo alles klar ist balu hat
wirklich viele sachen den gekriegt ich
bin echt eigentlich stolz auf dem ich
glaube wir können wenn mir jetzt sagt
wir machen auf jeden fall einen der
ersten 30 bin begeistert der troisdorfer
von deinen ganzen löhnen hier bevor reiz
und sie ist jetzt auch wunderschön aus
an alle die geschrieben dass balu totes
nein er lebt noch er ist nicht
verdursten glitzert schön er ist
wunderschön satt und er hat ein wenig
lust zwar lud ringt jetzt einfach noch
ein bisschen wasser wald mir gleich
welchen mehrwert bestreiten
meine damen und herren das ist ja
wundervoll dass ihr wieder alles
kommentiert es ist noch komplett egal
wer eine führung liegt meine damen und
herren der wir das ganze trotzdem reißen
sein kleiner bruder da wir wurden links
in die kommentare gestehen dass der
blues hier in dem spiel einfach der
zwillingsbruder von um hier ist das da
auf die idee bin ich gar nicht gekommen
online kommt ja sowieso fehler
wieso denn nur fehler
diesen fehler habe ich hab nicht auf
geachtet nur wie lange müsste ich mich
komplett gut weil es tut mir leid ich
habe dich aber leider in die falsche
richtung geschickt mit abzügen von 15
punkten von 48 sekunden ist mops paloma
von pedro den zweiten tag mit abschlägen
von zehnder zeit von bmw holt sich
schnauzer pepper und erst mit abzügen
von 535 ist schnauzer peter schieber nur
von balu von jj mit abzügen von 35 meter
zeit von 9 40 klasse gemacht ballo ballo
erinnert mich an die alte dame aus
meiner nachbarschaft alles klar ich
würde mich schon als jemanden
beschreiben der lieber gewinn als
verliert deswegen machen wir das ganze
jetzt einfach noch mal genau und jetzt
hier durchlaufen war nun genau das
machst du wundervolle wundervolle
wundervolle wundervolle und jetzt es
gibt mit dem man sehr gut und jetzt
aufgedeckt den wunderbaren super super
super das passt ganz klassisch auf jede
wächst mit den banken und den 6 damit
unternimmt auch noch den sieg mit dem
pokal ein preisgeld von 100 euro wahl
was machst du denn mit diesem scheiß
pokal schon wieder man wir wollten uns
ja als nächsten hit einen zwergpudel
kaufen und die kosten 595 dafür brauchen
wir noch 70 euro wieder 70 euro werden
uns im nächsten teil holen damit wir
nämlich noch hindernis parcours dann
kriegen wir noch 100 euro und dann holen
wir uns neuen hund das heißt es in der
nächsten folge machen beendet
wir sehen uns freunde wir sehen uns
herein